my mom she's like do not go for your
dreams that's too dangerous but like my
dad was more like hey you [__] go for it
now he was like what do you want to be
on your deathbed and be like all I ever
did was Physical Therapy he was like
you're going to feel like a [__]
loser he was like you should go for
comedy and go for it now he's like can
you live in my basement until you make
it you just [__] live here and he goes
it'll be our little secret you don't
have to tell your mother tell her you're
still a physical therapist but just quit
he was like quit tomorrow he was like
[__] that my mom didn't mean anything by
it she wasn't trying to deter me she was
like you just have an education you have
health insurance you're making $50,000 a
year like what more do you want